I came to the GSB back in 2003 from
England originally so I worked in the UK
and Europe for about five six years
before going to business school I moved
from the internet scene in Europe to the
major leagues of the internet in Silicon
Valley if you're an actor or actress
Hollywood is the place where you want to
go because that's where it's all
happening and I say one time software
entrepreneur in Europe that's how I felt
about the Silicon Valley so it was my
dream to come here Silicon Valley and
start a tech company here and GSB seemed
like an amazing stepping stone to
actually accomplish that often spending
the first year at Stanford myself and a
few classmates were looking for
somewhere to live and I started looking
online which seemed to be the place that
I go for most decisions where I was
buying an airplane ticket or buying an
iPod and I was astounded at the lack of
information around this pretty big
decision where you choose to live and
that inspired me to think about okay how
could this be transformed by technology
Trulia is different than any other real
estate website truly provides
information on real estate you can look
at these things you can see them on a
map and with one click you can contact
the real estate agent or the property
manager
a truly we don't want to help people
just find information property we want
to find the right home for them and
that's understanding property
information as well as crime information
what's it like to live in that
neighborhood so we've overlay crime
information with property information so
you can visually see it on a map the
second year of business called 2004-2005
this Stanford Business School Class S
356 startup garage was very much
instrumental in launching Trulia so Pete
and myself we got into the class and
it's a wonderful opportunity to go from
zero to 60 miles an hour as an
entrepreneur as a founder or were just
two semesters I remember the day we
graduated the very next Monday we have
meetings with top named VCS looking for
investments so we had a lot of the
pieces of the puzzle figured out before
we graduated in June 2005 it was three
of us myself my co-founder Pete and Luis
the computer scientists from Stanford
who were working out of basically a
corner of Stanford Business School
Library and today we are probably trade
a company with hundreds and hundreds of
employees significant revenues and I'd
like to say nationally recognized brand
time after time after time I realized
that if you dream and if you dream big
it's actually the first necessary step
in making dreams happen the most
difficult decision that any entrepreneur
faces is the very first one which is to
actually burn the lifeboats and go for
it
if you think of technology and you think
of entrepreneurship you think of Silicon
Valley and you look at the companies
that come out of Silicon Valley they
often come out of Stanford and Stanford
is at the epicenter of a global
technology and entrepreneurship
revolution
you